Aujourd'hui les amis, nous allons piéger les clients d'une boulangerie.
Nous allons tenter de faire croire à ces clients que Dustin est un vrai boulanger.
Vous êtes prêts ?
Team Foufou !
Dustin y est. La boulangerie ouvre dans quelques minutes...
Juste le temps pour lui d’enfiler sa tenue de boulanger.
Tu nous reçois Dustin ?
Je vous reçois cinq sur cinq, les mecs.
Sache que t’as l’air d’un vrai petit chef !
Arrêtez de déconner, faut que je me concentre.
Le premier client arrive.
Voyons voir comment Dustin va gérer ça.
Bonjour.
Bonjour !
Ca marche trop bien !
Pour l’instant c’est un sans faute !
Je vais vous prendre deux baguettes pas trop cuites.
Très bien !
Ça fait un euros quatre-ving dix, s'il vous plaît.
Merci.
Merci beaucoup !
Merci, au-revoir.
Bonne journée !
Comment t’as su les baguettes qu’il fallait choisir ?
J’ai pris celle qui avaient l’air le moins cuites.
Bien joué mec !
Les amis, Dustin s’en sort à merveille depuis tout à l’heure.
Personne ne s’est rendu compte du subterfuge.
Bonjour.
Bonjour, monsieur !
Mais regardez bien ce qu’il va se passer maintenant.
Je vais vous prendre une baguette tradition, s'il vous plaît.
Très bien, tout de suite, monsieur.
Vous êtes nouveaux ici, non ?
Ne stresse surtout pas, Dustin !
Merde ! Mais qu’est ce qu’il peut répondre?
Dis-oui ! Dis-oui, Dustin !
Oui.
Je me disais aussi.
Bonne journée.
Merci, parfait !
P***** de merde !
Applaudissez l'artiste !
Tu nous a foutu une de ces frousses, la frousse de l'année, enfoiré !
Bien joué mec !
Tout le monde te prend pour un vrai boulanger, le piège a fonctionné à merveille !
Je vous cache pas que j'ai bien stressé.
Mais je me suis pas fait démasquer !
Je pense que la personne qui veut démasquer la team foufou…
A du pain sur la planche !
Et c’est une mission accomplie pour la team foufou !
Encore une fois tout le monde n’y a vu que du feu !
Là je me suis fait piéger pour... pour la télé ?
Non mais j'ai pas vu.
Non j'ai pas vu de...
De quoi ? Que c'était pas le...
C'était pas le boulanger habituel ? Parce que normalement c'est le grand brun...
Quel est le... Quel est l'intérêt, du coup ? Parce que c'est....